people without even doing a gut
microbial test people are left and right
they're intervening there's no evidence
right uh so from ideal dietary
intervention uh there has to be evidence
back so we always talk about
evidence-based medicine especially when
you want to offer a personalized
medicine when I recommend something
whether I say go for a keto diet or a
caveman diet or intermittent fasting
whatever it is on what basis have been
making that does it fit everybody right
if you talk to people and say okay it
doesn't work for me I have tried fasting
it doesn't work for me right so let us
know one size fits all approach so if
you want to personalize a weight loss
therapies uh some kind of intervention
for weight loss or a wellness nutrition
and wellness the only way you can
personalize this is by doing hand gut
microbeam test and then you can evaluate
them based on this kind of clinical
correlations then you can personalize
that especially in obesity uh dysbiosis
is a very commonly associated especially
also in the senior citizens company and
above and its characteristics been a
very high levels of the battery is
lineages in that particular population
but we suspect it could be privately in
the Asian population and among the
background on that two that two
phenotype is highly likely uh disease
Associated and here we have looked at
the influence of the live microorganism
supplement they did see some improvement
but then it's not a huge huge
Improvement uh maybe the time duration
was very smart small and uh they only
have around 100 100 to 200 volunteers so
10 percent weight loss is what they have
documented uh with the supplements uh
but definitely there are some
improvement in the in the dysbiosis with
the supplements but again the
questionnaire is are these the right
kind of supplements right so are we
fixing this backed on back to uh ratio
uh does the supplement actually address
that that's that's some something they
they discussed in the discussion section
they said maybe supplement is not the
right one right so so it's not only
enough to personalize the diagnostic
test we also need to personalize the
supplements so that means uh depending
on prototypes this is what we are
proposing uh we don't think it's just
three types of four types we think that
could be at least uh 21 different input
types right it's it can get more and
more complex but we from based on
whatever data we are seeing uh globally
people fall under measure these three or
four groups but then when you look at
all the subtypes under each groups under
dominant operas bacteria it is
21 different major second level second
tier and prototypes are emerging then
there are like 64 000 miners that comes
in the in the algorithms so nobody has
the patience to look at 64 000 so forget
about that but at least 21 days 21 major
Enterprise you can look at and then I
can have 21 different capsules right so
let's say you are falling into type one
three and seven I'll give you the
capsules one and three and seven right
so I'll have the what is the missing in
your gut microbiome I will try to
replenish that so that is something that
we are working on uh so in this
particular study they have looked at the
diversity is very important so they
mainly look at the diversity but a lot
of things you can look at and they have
looked at this interesting occurrency or
Museum so that's very interesting
because this is a very important
bacteria which creates that mucinous
layer in the in the intestinal colon
epithelium which is protecting the
epithelium from all these dangerous
infections for example you must have
already in covid not only the
respiratory infection you also have a
gut infection and that's why we have
coronavirus circulating in the waste
water and there have been many studies
with nanopore Wastewater surveillance
right from communities uh High
prevalence communities wherever the
kovid virus you can find it in the water
because of the gut infections just like
polio virus recently I was surprised in
UK there was a study they actually found
polio virus polio virus was still
circulating even though the snow cases
but polymers is still found in the way
when they were looking for Coronavirus
they found polio viruses it's still
there you know so we we think polio is
eradicated but then it always comes back
then we have monkey pox and then now
even cows a lot of cows are being
infected with lumpy skin disease that's
again belongs to some kind of virus so
the beneficial bacteria like
ackermansion uh also some other uh some
of some other good bacteria uh so the EU
bacterium right it's under a couple of
other things uh so either it is uh an
increase of abnormal bad bacteria or it
is a loss of the good bacteria right so
so it's an imbalance